just good morning it's wednesday and
roll dog and i are headed down to
uh we're going to the paddler's
warehouse we're going to go meet our
paddlers today
right mike fields we're going to meet
we're going to meet up with uh mike
field and a one of the things that's
going on
is that uh we got hooked up through my
coach chris health we got hooked up
with the top paddlers on the island it's
a growing sport
and uh these guys are studs mike field
is uh if not the top paddler on the
island
one of the top guys travels all over the
world racing
just got back from tahiti oh wow and
uh he's racing with uh i believe he's
racing
for livestrong right now so these guys
are super studs
uh it's a huge honor to be uh
hooked up with these guys i mean these
guys are
top notch of condolences so we're gonna
go over to their warehouse where they
keep all their boats
i think it's amazing that uh that mike
uh basically emailed his brothers his
other paddlers and was like jason lester
needs a paddler and within minutes there
was like responses saying i'm in
so that just goes to show you the aloha
spirit here on the island
hey cruz so we just stepped over here to
the uh
to the warehouse and uh we wanted to
show you this
here he's the navigator
and we got odie over here who builds uh
who builds canoes actually this is where
these guys hang out they keep all their
toys
and uh they've been kind enough to uh
step in and help us out
these guys are the studs on the island
so uh we're very blessed to uh
have these guys be gracious enough to uh
help us out so
how are you guys blessed enough to hook
up with livestrong that's awesome that's
a great question it kind of i mean
it was it was kind of a beautiful thing
as like i would um
i was racing and uh
i got a friend involved in it and we
were doing so many
um races that required you know
entry fees all right neighbor islands
and this and that and
i was always you know struggling to find
sponsorship to
to pay for it and to get that to the
barge and back and forth
and uh he uh this friend of ours was
saying hey well
you know instead of um going with all
these different things let's just go
under one umbrella right just
fully support live strong and make a big
impact that way right so uh we went that
direction and
so you got like one one of your guys is
tight with the
live strong organization or how do you
ever tell him he's just tight with lance
right and lance gave us his blessing and
and we've been very very careful about
you know taking baby steps on anything
that we do and
keep them involved and try to do the
best we can that's awesome
and and train as hard as we can and and
also try to help send the message out
there
you know pretty cool yeah but you guys
are
you guys are pure vegetarians right yeah
raw or you know how killer is that to go
ultra marathon
with with no animal products you don't
yeah so trying to create a little
yeah awareness that you know because i
think there's a lot of
you know i mean most people obviously
would think oh there's no way you can be
an athlete
without eating you know animal without
eating meat and steaks and chipping and
you know getting
getting your protein that way and yeah
and i think just eating clean and eating
you know
organic and having the foods to be as
close to their natural state
as possible you know has the highest
nutritional value yeah you know and i've
just found that
you know i've gotten stronger and leaner
and i recover faster between workouts
and
i just you know if i didn't feel good
like it started out like before
getting back into sports i started the
diet because i was like i turned 40 i
was like 210 pounds
just didn't feel good want to get back
in shape and like gave this a try
and then i was like man i got so much
energy like i need to do you know like
what am i going to do with all this
energy and then kind of like finding
that kind of led me into the ultra world
but that kind of nutrition shift started
first
everyone's different you know like i'm
not trying to tell people what to do
everyone yeah but you know like this is
i'm just sharing
kind of like what i've been doing that's
been working for me but inspire people
it's cool and like there's been a lot of
people have been like oh i just bought a
like yeah i get emails like i just
bought a vitamix like
i was just like should be getting paid
by vitamix
you know it was kind of off the radar i
was watching the tahitians actually
where
a machete after canoe race in uh in in
samoa and just like
they had like a like a dive bag yeah all
coconuts and they just
instead of drinking your gatorade or
your water they just go extra
yeah the coconut water is super high in
electrolytes
better than gatorade now we're at the
point where we want to uh
we're we're convincing everyone to get
bikes and now we're going to start
using the bike as our cardio so we're
not having to burn out
you know our upper body right and use
the lower body to kill
to build our heart and lungs you guys
probably do you do a lot of core work
not as much as we should but we're
realizing that that's it's all core
i mean like especially stand up right
yeah would be
it'd be great to collaborate and um and
pick your brain yeah
and and and when we start getting the
bike scene going
yeah you can kind of stop for us
nutrition is huge and
you know rich and i have been hanging
out the past month he's been out here
for like you know three weeks and
just his knowledge as you see in the in
the videos and stuff on just uh the
plant-based diet's just been
amazing and vibrant but but odie like
you jason
is is just trying to do some really cool
things with
the youth around town oh yeah and keep
people going and
um we store our spearing head in this
thing called life pursuits
oh my god here's kind of our little fun
think tank so
you know nice but this is kind of prank
style you know
pure it's a little bit of a mike's
artwork right
what's the website it's uh
enfield.rt.com
check it out and then od does pure
pure paddles is there a website for that
pure panels calm check it out
this was like a long time ago oh you
said you did the poster for the
the six mile swim from this is this is
the mile swim one this is yeah it just
happened
yeah that was a couple years back but
that's kind of the whole fun style and
that was just taken off of copelago
double haul
yeah this is odi's workshop
it's where they get the paddles made
this is another livestrong
boat this is
years ago that uh was a sitting idle and
um
so yeah just refurbishing and he's got
these nice little dovetail
pieces in there
this is what it looks like before you uh
carve it down yeah start there and then
just look at this here
you want to end up like that wow dave
still stand over here sanding it
mike and mike and odie great guys
great brothers great people to have in
your life and just
full-on givers man and we're just we
just feel so blessed and honored to
to have them jump on board with us for
the ultraman and so they're going to be
um
that crew is going to be our paddlers
we're going to go hang out with them in
the next couple days down in the water
and
and check out the check out the currents
and everything so
we gave you a little peek inside of uh
inside their their warehouse as you can
see you can see the livestrong
um boat in there you know they're
full-on
yeah a couple like we saw two livestrong
boats so they're full on
sponsored by livestrong and so we're
going to give a shout out to lance right
now lance the boys are doing it for you
the boys are so stoked to represent live
strong and
they're uh keep doing it spreading the
word
we are super super lucky
to have those guys around to uh
support us those are the top paddlemen
on the island
and uh not only are they unbelievable
athletes
and uh you know basically students of
the currents
they're carrying a really positive
message
for the people on this island they're
doing really cool stuff
they're being of service to their
community and uh
and it's just a really good vibe you
know they got this warehouse over there
they're making their own
paddles they're making their own boats
they're employing uh
locals and you know they're putting the
message out to kids
and the community about what they're
doing they're raising awareness for good
causes
and it's just generally like a super
good vibe over there wouldn't you say
like super positive and just it's
amazing that uh
you know we were able to connect with
these people we just spent i mean i
think we were there for two hours
talking to those guys and they would
have talked to us all day oh yeah so
they just opened up their
basically their home to us and you know
gave us a tour inside and uh
it was a really cool thing so we're
feeling uh pretty excited about that
relationship so we're going to check in
with you guys later but
what an awesome experience plant strong
land plant strong
keep it up live strong